Dr guy is getting of taking out
Dei I want to come to his office and let
him know that we will fight him more of
the media running cover here's Al
Sharpton a deflating he's a def the man
is deflating every time I look at him I
think he's deflating saying that
Claudine gay is mostly uh they're going
after her well because she's black she's
a woman blah blah blah gays somehow get
in therei was to make up for the jial
historic of black of women of gays of
ASI and since W decided that he would
stand up and say that taking out Dr guy
is beginning of taking out
Dei I want to come to his office and let
him know that we will fight him we said
nothing when the fight was in h but now
he's declared against all of us
something we must have toize
the that's why we today Dei is something
we must have to equalize the playing
field no not in the things that I'm
going to be part of not in the way
America was set up to be not in the
things that will lead us to the future
if you want Dei now I get it Al Sharpton
you you are racist you have a long track
record of racist uh uh comments and
actions you're you're one of the biggest
race hustlers uh in this entire country
um so if you want to keep running with
that then you will go ahead but we must
make Dei diie it is as simple as that
she would not be in trouble right now
had she not
plagiarized right are you saying that
the that they're going after her because
she's a black woman the media was nobody
had a problem with the president of
Harvard before any of this then it came
out that she's a plagiarist do black
people not care about plagiarism as I
said the woman stole from another black
scholar another black female
scholar lordy lordy but the point of all
of this guys is that when you take all
of these bad ideas that we've been
talking about and then you just
proliferate them throughout a society
then the good people the few good people
remaining you watching this right now
and the samean people who are out there
we all get pinned as the bad guys right
Al Sharpton would gladly call me a
racist he would gladly call you a racist
and in some ways that is what now the
overriding uh I would say thesis behind
the entire Democrat Party platform is if
you are either one of us you are either
an intersectional Dei wster or you are a
[Music]
racist